dans les années 70 tout comme
aujourd'hui les cyclistes demandé plus
de place dans la ville plus de vélo
moins d'autos il voulait rouler en toute
sécurité car à l'époque circulaient en
ville relever du défi presque aucune
piste cyclable exemple à paris tout le
monde s'est aperçu des problèmes que
pose la circulation d'un deux roues dans
une grande ville qu'est ce qu'on
pourrait faire d'après vous pour
améliorer la circulation des deux roues
dans les villes peut-être
créer des couloirs spéciaux bien j'ai
pas mal pour moi
favoriser le
d'euros par rapport à la voiture au
moindre
c'est le moyen de locomotion le plus
pratique andine les années passent et
les infrastructures se met timidement en
place strasbourg fait alors office de
ville pionnière au milieu des années 90
elle se vante d'avoir 150 km de pistes
cyclables
alors qu'au même moment paris lance son
premier plan vélo mais à en croire les
cyclistes la construction de voies
aménagées n'allait pas assez vite
15 km par an pendant trois ans c'est
rien du tout avec la pression automobile
en ce moment il faut 50 km par an
pendant 5 ou 10 ans d'autres villes
prennent aussi le virage de la petite
reine
renault bhl par exemple a mis en place
des autoroutes pour vélo au milieu des
années 2010 elle est d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui la ville qui a le plus de
voiries aménagées en france tout a été
pensé pour la voiture maintenant il faut
le repenser pour une mixité des usages
entre les voitures les vélos et
transports en commun faire des sites
propres
ces aménagements la qui coûte cher
aujourd'hui des aménagements qui coûte
cher mais qui sont aussi devenu un
argument politique
à paris la mère anne hidalgo s'était
engagé à avoir 1400 km de voies
aménagées pour les vélos d'ici 2020 on
est loin du compte il y en a aujourd'hui
900 km en sachant que le terme voix
aménagé comprend outre les pistes
cyclables sécurisées les zones 30
les marquages au sol et les voies de bus
qui ne sont pas forcément synonymes de
sécurité pour les cyclistes
[Musique]